all right Ryan it's time for bed okay
take a little nap
thank you mate good night bedbugs bite
there's no bedbugs is there this vial I
told you to take care of that 15 minutes
before Ryan's up all I need is one
oh that's Ryan's handwriting okay
what is she doing up I am running I am
running away because because because you
think I farted when I didn't yes you
mean the movies oh my god
[Laughter]
[Music]
paper ryan's running away running
running where don't worry my daughter is
missing I don't know what to do hey I
need your help
yeah okay father John I yeah sorry but
Papa John's um yeah I would like a large
pizza
root beer and one of those larger
cookies that you guys yeah that'd be
great
okay thank you hurry yes thank you
little day boy I could possibly look no
luck she's dead no great there's the
arrangements hello ladies first
oh honey we were so scared we're so
sorry for making fun of you for farting
but I didn't fart
listen Ryan it's natural everyone does
it there's mommy fire oh no
hey listen maybe it was a sneaky leaky
what's that
alright sneaky leaky pay attention this
one's one of my personal favorite it's
like a tire that has a hole in it and
then it's leaking but you never know
what's leaking until you feel different
in this case much better I swear it
wasn't me it wasn't hi I got an order
for a minute
great thank you
[Music]
you were late I got here in a minute
yeah but I ordered a two liters oh no no
you didn't the customer's always right
you listen I know I know I gotta cook
another call on the one she's gonna
mommy please tell daddy it wasn't me
Ryan that is enough lies out of you now
if you want some of this pizza you're
gonna have to apologize to mommy and
daddy I'm sorry mommy
I'm sorry daddy maybe I had a sneaky
meet okay honey good job all right let's
go eat some pizza
whoa yeah you did yeah you did
I smelt it I heard it was that's right
it was you this whole time wasn't it
okay my bad you to do I want a divorce
you conserved I still see her you know I
want a hundred percent custody
this is uncalled for
[Music]